four years after Flint Michigan's water
crisis first captured nationwide
attention the new jersey city of newark
also faces questions about its water
supply about 15,000 lead pipes provide
water to homes and parts of the city
newark officials had insisted that the
water was safe but state testing found
elevated lead levels filters are now
being distributed in the city is facing
a lawsuit from a non-profit on behalf of
residents there Anna Warner's outside
Newark City Hall with more on this story
and a good morning good morning Gail
well you know roughly one-quarter of
Newark kids under the age of six have
detectable levels of lead in their blood
and any level of lead for children is
dangerous now Newark dealt with an issue
of lead in water at some schools back in
2016 but city officials had assured
residents they say that their city
drinking water was safe now they have
questions for City Hall I was extremely
upset extremely upset the water coming
from Yvette Jordan's tap looks pure but
this year she learned it contained lead
levels nearly three times federal rules
something she says she didn't expect
because of what she'd been hearing from
city officials your water's fine
everything's fine that's what you heard
from the city yes through several robo
calls through a press conference from
our mayor everything is fine but the
city is now telling residents in some
areas their tap water is not fine it
contains lead above federal guidelines
they're handing out these water filters
and telling parents their babies and
young children should not drink the
water
mayor raspberr akka says the problem
comes from old water pipes found in some
neighborhoods that leach led into the
drinking water you have some homes that
have no lead in their water at all we
have be very little led and there's some
homes that have elevated land our job to
be prudent is to have somebody do a
study and figure out what actually is
going on the study report came back last
month and found a problem at one of the
city's two water treatment plants the
methods used to
led from leaching into drinking water
from those old pipes weren't working we
acted immediately to address what was
happening but Erik Olson with the
nonprofit group Natural Resources
Defense Council says reports show the
city's knowledge of lead in its water
goes back to early 2017 the city has
really been in denial and shrugged their
shoulders and said our water is safe
people should drink it until just a
couple of weeks ago after we sued them
and asked for an injunction on behalf of
the citizens in Newark to clean up the
water the group is suing the city for
violating the federal drinking water law
saying the lead levels are some of the
highest of any large city nationally a
problem they compared to that of Flint
Michigan a case similar to Flint where
the government was not telling people
the truth you know I take offense to
that because what happened in Flint is
not what's happening here are you
worried that some children may now have
been exposed to let well I'm worried
that our kids are exposed to that all at
a time I think the water thing is sexy
and everybody has jumped on it because
of Flint water is not contributed in any
significant way to the elevated levels
in our children's blood lead-based paint
and dust has done that in the City of
Newark and I would suspect in middie
City many cities across America the city
says it's changing the way it treats
water at the treatment plant that had
the problem it's also embarking on a
plan to replace lead water pipes that
but that will take some time possibly
years to get all of that done meanwhile
the NRDC s lawsuit is proceeding and
Yvette Jordans
workers group has joined in that lawsuit
Fiona and Anna as we just heard concerns
about drinking water are not just in
Newark and in Flint they're across the
country so if people at home are
concerned what should they do well one
thing you can do is reach out to your
local utility find out what their tests
have found see if you can get
information there sometimes they post
those online there are some at home
water testing kits that you can also use
or you could call in a professional to
help you with that bianna
and some really important tips thank you
such an important story because as we
all know the data is clear lead leads to
intellectual brain delays and that's why
I always remember that's the one test
they've really give all kids you got to
get the lead tester because it's so
serious
and as we said there should be a
nationwide concern